welcome to the fbi's
second least popular division the
unusual incidence
unit most of you are probably here as a
punishment
because someone wants you out of their
hair and if you here because you told
your superiors the truth
and they didn't believe it uh just what
well then i'm gonna need to make a
demonstration
you see the uiu is a joke
but not for the reason you guys think
i'm sure most of you will recognize this
as a desert eagle it's loaded with 50
caliber bullets
so seven rounds in the magazine let's
count them out
one two three
four five six
seven eight nine
ten eleven i keep going but i'll hand
the magazine around so you can see i'm
not using sleight of hand
so if what we're investigating is real
why are we a joke because we're way out
of our depth
you guys aren't trained for the sort of
stuff we're meant to be investigating
of course you do get really good
bereavement benefits
pop quiz how many rounds are there in
that magazine
nope the guy i found it on thought it
was limitless too
it holds 1296 rounds
he ran out while shooting at me
now for the terminology we dealing carts
and cans a card is a confirmed artifact
an object that doesn't belong within
this world a can
is a confirmed anomaly an event or area
that involves something
impossible a canned man is a person who
is a novelist
these tend to be particularly dangerous
and you'll probably find someone else is
looking for them
we're not the only ones dealing with
this stuff when you're out on an
investigation keep your eyes out for
other interested parties
the suits men in suits sunglasses
who works your stereotypical spooks
men are black if you get a chance keep
your eyes on them
they're bastards completely
untrustworthy but if they give you an
order
you follow it they work for the
government apparently and
they outrank us the fireworks
militia groups highly trained sometimes
armed with carts
we figure there's more than one we've
seen them fighting each other
they come in and take or destroy
whatever it is they're after
then they leave and we have to cover it
up don't try and interfere without
backup
and be aware that they're better
equipped than us they're dangerous
ruthless and vicious but at least
they're honest
if they give you an order follow it if
you don't
they kill you the cart shoppers
marshall carter dart they're an auction
house
and a gentleman's club their customers
are extremely rich and tend to have
rather
disturbing tastes official policy is
derailed and you know
car dealers but you should be very
careful around m c
and d their security forces don't want
to make a scene so
wait for backup before going in and you
should be relatively safe
if they give you an order well
decide for yourselves assuming you have
free will at the time
the can collection they call themselves
the serpent's hand
they only interfere with the actions of
other groups generally to free
or protect canned men they're happy to
use artifacts
and have very little interest in secrecy
they understand anomalies better than
most because
most of them seem to be anomalies do not
confront them in public
you won't win and the suits will be
annoyed about having to clean up your
mess
if they give you an order consider
following it they can probably
set you on fire with their mind and
finally
the guys that we actually get on with
the skippers
you'll know they're there you'll see
something labeled
soap and care products superior consumer
produce
sudden career possibilities or security
for corporate profiteers
they're not trying to hide from us just
from the public
the skippers are well trained know what
they're doing and
they're helpful their aim seems to be
similar to ours
find anomalies quietly and get them
under control and have the public eye
if they're there then the problem's
probably out of your league
but you can go and introduce yourself if
you like if they ask you for help
well i'll make sure your family are
looked after if you die
in addition to the standard bereavement
package from us
if you receive a call starting with hey
skipper
it means there's something they can't be
bothered dealing with it's almost
certainly a minor artifact
those things help us keep our funding so
make sure to take skipper calls
seriously if a skipper gives you an
order
follow it because while they probably
won't kill you
the anomaly will i once took orders from
a pizza delivery guy
didn't even realize it was from spicy
crust pizza ring until it was all over
that is why we're a joke
you